monstead Has Fallen its great Army
decimated by the legions of a deer the
demon god
but one light still flickers any
ever-growing Gloom the light of the dark
crusader
the radiance of monsters
foreign
[Music]
ascends to Aureus my child
as His Holy Redeemer
in light we walk in lights we walk
burn
very souls to have
your flesh has been made sacrosanct with
the mark of the dark Crusaders
I'm a man who
knew who's alone and when I'm walking a
dark road at night are strolling through
the mouth
great potential dwells within your
doubtless for you to be chosen firstly
[Music]
prove yourself worthy of this gift
by your Radiance grant me the strength
to continue to endure these dark days
[Music]
another unfortunate made a slave to
unceasing hunger
I pity you
reignite the Blessed beacons of monstada
and thwart ideas
[Music]
thank you
foreign